[Music]
shot clock is four
Jokers has to put it up falling away
puts it up dang
IC knocks it down his foot was on the
line a two-pointer what a shot
that's a tough shot how about that
means Paul behind his head like
that he made the one in what game two
yep same thing
the jokic just gets it off in time it's
up
in
out Anthony Davis just stares at him 12
assists even the desperation shots go in
[Music]
the first second quarter Murray gets
inside back to yolkit shot clock winding
down yolk has to put it up high awesome
three oh he knocks it down
stepping backwards falling falling
points
you could feel the nervousness in this
building everyone's standing jokic here
comes the reigning two-time MVP Fades
and sticks it again
and then jokish with a big time step
back and we have a ball game the other
ones the Lakers got to put him in a
position to be aggressive
jokic
let's just drops it down
passes do it all and we're gonna watch
him if Anthony Davis can't guard this
nobody in the league can
[Applause]
yokic patient draws three still takes
and floats it in
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you supposed to do here
what are you supposed to do
you'll get your score their last seven
six seconds
backing down biyombo to the Box fades
[Applause]
unreals going to their stars in the okay
with the beautiful thing and the Finish
back out to jokic two on the shot clock
hoisting off ballast jumper oh it finds
net daddy traveled let's take a look no
that's a good shot
but that possession started with him
getting double teamed
in the post
drifting back to the perimeter making
this
[Music]
nine to shoot Barton out to jokic
jokic's Falling Away
[Applause]
jokish buries it
he's done official he thought he got
slapped on the arm again
it's a two-pointer
jokic
five to shoot
a little Fade Away jumper splash
wow
at meantime just
an incredible shot by jokuch at the
other end
free to fire
you fired
to get him on that right side
a little one-legged and he worked he's
worked
[Applause]
the jokic loves that shot and hits the
sambore shuffle you look at the size of
bobon's hand folks look at him
challenging this so bust out that
sambore shuffle off one foot over
beaupon are you kids win for Denver
stops a three-game losing streak they
had lost five of six but they come in
heok
Harris in the lane strip got it back
tightrope
shot clocks at five border into jokic
jokish
[Music]
[Applause]
jokic will turn at the base
came the clock look at the clock two at
right at two seconds he's shooting about
a 17 and a half 19 foot Fade Away jump
shot Dirk Nowitzki style
trying to get the ball to jokic and they
finally do five on the clock
jokic's turn Shuffle
board Shuffle yes
and now jokic
Joker's 28 points tonight and the basket
is good and a foul
well Nicola jokic and falling in Nicola
jokic against Karl Anthony towns a
little step back
takes the contact but it doesn't matter
he can handle it knocks down that fade
away jumper
now Morris with it nuggets down by one
shot talks at three yocus Shuffle is
good
[Applause]
here's the one shot clock going down the
step back
baby more skilled George switches on to
jokic Fade Away jumper good toyed with
him and made the bucket the lead up to
this used to frustrate me in the park
that guy with his hat on and a cigarette
I'm still mad at him with the black
socks
Sambora Shuffle over buchevich got it
so there's the free throw story as Katie
mentioned the Buck's getting there a lot
but they missed seven nuggets not
getting there very much at all
but they've made nine out of ten
now jokic it's gonna some more Shuffle
got it
sees the night time 15 points eight
assists couple of steals now jokic
against lamb soundboard Shuffle is good
take that
so you can say with youngsters I used to
play a little bit yeah yeah I could do a
little bit of this myself
as Murray is around the corner backhands
it to jokic he's got five to shoot in on
Carter a little step back and he's got
it so Nicola jokic on the board seven to
shoot
jokic has it against Stephen Adams who's
back in sambar shot got it beautiful
Sabor Shuffle Adam sets up to him
afterwards right there